I mentioned Halloween is the template
for scream and as the main antagonist
Billy is very aware of that he sees
Lorie Strode hiding in the closet and
realizes that Sydney must be doing the
same however before he can act she
strikes first by stabbing him with an
umbrella causing him to drop the knife
and the gun he's saved when Stu uses the
last of his energy to bum rush her but
she's able to put him out of commission
in the living room Randy comes back too
so Billy swiftly knocks him back out
with a punch to the face and pins down
Sydney telling her to say hello to her
mother she Jabs a finger into his wound
causing him to scream out and just
before can thrust his knife down onto
her a recently reawakened Gail weathers
shoots him in the chest guess I remember
the safety that time you bastard this
might have been enough to kill the
normal person but I like to believe that
Billy was so motivated to make his life
a movie that he held on just a little
bit longer so he could have that one
last scare moment that he had seen in so
many of his favorite films Sydney is
ready for it though and delivers a head
shot to put an end to the terror that
plagued Woodsboro over the last year